hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
a novel automated and simultaneous
protein
antibody height throughput purification
platform
amag and its reusable mag beads
i'm susie valdez of labrutz and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elaborates
and brought to you by genscript to learn
more
visit genscript.com now we encourage you
to participate
in today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation this
presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
please follow the process to obtain
those credits by clicking
on the continuing education credits
window
i'd now like to introduce our speaker dr
waylon liu
a technical and sales account manager at
gen script
waylon welcome you may now begin your
presentation everyone
uh i'm wayland james the eu account
manager in charge of amax
sa plus technical support and sales uh
it's my good pleasure to give you guys
talk on our amac
sa plus and its magnetic system
to give you guys impression on this
automated and high throughput
protein and antibody purification
platform
my presentation consists of by several
parts uh the first
part i'll be talking about current in
use protein purification platforms
in the second part i'll be focusing on
our amac sa
platform and its magnetic piece and i'll
also talk about our solutions to reduce
cell culture volume at the very end i
will summarize my talk
so here i want to give you a very brief
impression on current in use protein
platforms in the correct market
from a simple gravity column that's what
you can see
on the left the first photo you load
one sample each time you just simply
wait it's low cost
but however it's low throughput and low
efficient
and of course time consuming and the
second photo you can see
is probably the one that you have seen
in some labs
it's based on chromatographic column
purification system
the column is pre-packed but however you
still need to prepare your samples
to do a centrifugation and the
filtration
and the throughput capacity is medium
you can process
maximum 10 samples in eight hours
so and the price is quite expensive
still so when you talk about those
robotic and automated system as shown in
the photo 3 and the photo 4
you could see that they have a good
throughput capacity but however
when you look at automated system one i
call it system one
you could see that the throughput is
still medium it's about 60 samples per
six hours and of course you you still
need to prepare your samples
and the cost is way higher it's 200k
and when i talk about the last one
system two
it has better higher suit capacity but
however
you can only process samples with small
volumes
ranging from several hundred microliter
to fuel mills
so in order to feel this technical gap
and
make a better and more efficient uh
protein purification platform we jam
script
has developed a magnetic piece based
purification system
in collaboration with our mission to
further
improve the purification efficiency and
to achieve automation
and optimize purification so this figure
is basically shows how magnetic work uh
these purification works it's pretty
straightforward you put your beads in
culture with your cell culture medium
and after certain period
you get a magnetic source close to the
magnetic fields
and these get absorbed together with
your protein of interest
you pour the medium out then you
basically get your protein and
antibodies
so this process is very straight
forward it doesn't require the
centrifugation
and no infiltration is needed and of
course
it's low cost in instant instrumentation
and no column assembly is required and
more importantly um
its automation on this process is pretty
feasible
to achieve a high throughput so
in order to achieve automation and
higher throughput
we haven't developed this amac as a
plus system that's what you can see on
the right upper corner photo
this is how this apparatus looks like so
the main features of this amex s8 system
is it's magnetically based the
purification
at records and it has complete
automation
process ranging from
washing to illusion
to stripping and
also cleaning it has very short
purification
duration about 40 to 50 minutes you
finish
one complete run and it saves your labor
and time
and additionally as i just mentioned no
certification
and the filtration is needed you can
customize
up to you can save up to 50 customized
protocols
and additionally is a closed system so
basically it can minimize
endotoxins contamination and the
pollution
so perhaps you might have more time for
coffee literature discussion and paper
writing
so while you're talking when you talk
about the throughput capacity
this apparatus can process 12 samples at
a time
and each sample's volume can range from
5
to 50 mil and it can even go beyond with
those tools provided by
james gen spread bios and it can purify
protein and antibody up to 80 milligrams
and the minimum illusion volume is 0.4
mil or in other words 400 microliters
so with human kind always make me safe
especially while you process with many
samples
you might forget lost your lost your
track or swap your samples
but if you have a such machine a good
one and well-programmed one
so the machine doesn't make a mistake so
this is the
the moment that our amac s8 plus kick in
for high throughput experiments
and of course our interface is quite
user friendly
it's based on a touch screen so
basically you can change you can adjust
a parameters experiment by simply use
your finger
to push the touch button so it's pretty
intuitive a visual interface
as you can see on the picture on the
right hand side
so you can flexibly change your programs
by setting selection of your proteins or
your samples
by selection the the spot where your
sample is
and you can even change let's say
[Music]
cycle number cycle number and the buffer
volume
by simply touch the touchscreen so
this system also gives you a total
buffer usage
a notification to make sure you have
enough buffer
in each bottle it also reminds you the
remaining time of of
each experiment and this one has a usb
uh port as well for software update and
the protocol transfer
as i just mentioned it can save up to 50
protocols
so back to the this picture on your
right hand side
so you can see you can choose fields
basically to feel if the all the loops
and
all the tubes provide appropriate amount
of buffers so basically for washing
purpose and also
to wash the inner loop system in order
to avoid the system
of low errors instead of a solution
and you could also choose uv to do uv
sterilization
before and after each of your
experiments
to get a clean system so when you click
processing you enter this work interface
so what you can see on the left hand
side is
your sample selection panel where you
can choose
a1 a2 or from b1 to b2
in total 12 samples and moreover you can
also specifically point out
once false or two supports where your
samples are loaded
for instance if you have only have two
samples
you can choose a1 or a4 or a1 or a2
and the panel below is the place where
you can adjust your wash your buffer and
the port
connection so basically you can freely
choose and swap
a certain buffer with a corresponding
port
for instance you can switch buffer
one to port two or illusion buffer
one to port five and
moreover you can also change your cycle
numbers
so basically this interface gives you
quite straight enough flexibility
to you know choose different uh
connection
between ports and your buffer solutions
on the right right hand side side what
you can see
is more experimental details such as
magnetic base volume and illusion
wash buffer volumes and there at
the panel below you can even give each
let's say specific number for each spot
uh while you process to stripping so
basically you clean up your mathematics
you end up in a quite similar interface
so there you can choose your samples
choose your
sample experimental uh detail
information
and of course you can adjust your
buffer and the port connection but here
i want to emphasize is that
for the sodium hydroxide the port 7 is
specifically designed let's say or
dedicated
for this sodium hydroxide connection you
can't change it
okay so in comparison with the
traditional resin-based purification
from from incubation centrifugation
situation
column packing sample loading washing
illusion and regeneration and the manual
step
you need to do when you work with a mac
as a plot system is simply incubation
and then load your samples in wait for
about 45 to 50 minutes
then you get you are 12 samples purified
so again
it saves your time labor and makes
no mistake and this slide basically
shows the simple layout of
a mac as a plus a workstation
so what you can see on the left hand
side is a max station i call it
workstation
on the right hand side you see the
bottles for buffers and its connection
towards a mxs8 plus system and of course
using the waste bin connection of course
uh so the picture on the on the right
hand side
shows the layout of the port connection
as i mentioned
previously a mac s8 plus system provides
eight ports connection basically port
one to five
is for washing and illusion buffer for
your bees for your sample
for your nozzle etc etc so based on your
needs
just give you a five port selection
to allow you a quite freedom in buffer
and illusion
washing buffer selection and the
cleaning port
for the cleaning port you can use either
0.05 molar
hydrogen hydrochloric acid during
processing step
or you can choose 20 ethanol when you do
beat
streaking and for the sodium hydroxide
you could either choose
0.1 molar antibodies or
one molar for regular protein
purification and the port
8 is designed for waste collection so
all those compartments together
formed a closed system so to minimize
the pollution and contamination of
biomaterial
or biowaste and endotoxin
so here's a link i want to which can
give you more or less immediate
impression on how the system works
so here i want to use very short
demonstration with you to give you guys
more
viewed impression on how a mac iso
system works so here
is our amac acid plus system loading
magnetic beads in cell culture
for a certain period of incubation in
order to capture the protein of interest
so pour the samples into the 50ml tube
now move to the station switch on a mac
as a plus system
send your orders by simply touching the
screen
rack out put your samples in wreck in
get started so you see the nazo is
washing the bees
bees are very well suspended the
magnetic far
out bees get absorbed instantaneously
the nozzle is removing washing buffer
and nozzles do the same for the next six
samples
now they are moving back to the
reservoir for washing and
getting new buffer now it's removing and
pumping illusion buffers in see the
magnetic feeds are very well suspended
and it's doing the same for these six
samples and these are well suspended
magnetic fire outs bees get absorbed
instantaneously
so the only thing you need to do is to
remove illusion buffer containing your
protein of interest
and those smallings you can see uh
below actually is more detailed the
video instruction
divided by experimental steps for
instance
one give you introduction one give you
let's say how to prepare magnetic fields
etc etc so if you're interested please
go
and have a watch to get more impression
on that
okay so um basically to kind of
summarize our amac plus features uh
so this one this apparatus system can
approach us 12 samples at the time
and the minimum illusion volume is 0.4
mil and it gives you
and five different kinds of buffer
choice and
for each cycle for each experiment it
takes about 45 to
a 48 minutes and the magnetic beads
volume
can range from 0.1 to 2 mil
settled magnetic and amex plus
also has usb port basically for updating
software
and the data transfer and the related
channels you can use is
seven and the channels and the programs
are interchangeable and
customized it can save up to 50
protocols so here i want to talk about
another player in this system which is
magnetic fees
and we james produced a variety of
magnetic fields
for protein and also for antibody
purification that's the table you can
see here
we produce protein abs gbs we also
combine them together
for for antibody purification and more
importantly
i want to highlight the last one which
is our special design
amax protein a magnetic beast
it has a very high bonding capacity 40
milligram per meal
actually it can go up to 80 milligrams
per meal
it's alkaline tolerant it means that it
can be washed by sodium hydroxide
so that it can be reused up to 30 to 40
times
and of course we provide the bulk size
pricing
is available for all our magnetic fields
to further support what i just mentioned
to show our amex protein ac
capacity so here are more experimental
data
i will first start with this quick
response towards magnetic field
so in comparison with a supplier you can
see at
time zero nothing happened but after six
seconds when the magnetic field applies
you could see our amacb got absorbed
very well at the bottom whereas another
supply of bees are still kind of
suspending
in solution so it means that our bees
react
to magnetic fields very quickly and
also i believe our bonding capacity in
comparison with our our
other competitor is pretty comparable
and even
actually high in most cases that's what
you can see
on the left bottom corner figure
so why move to the alkaline resistance
data you could see
our uh protein amet protein abs
is quite um so it doesn't show obvious
decrease in binding capacity
even after 40 cycles and then
concerning about the protein leakage
again what you can see is that after
multiple times of reuse
our protein a b shows very low and a
minimum
protein a leakage
and when you talk about antibody
recovery in comparison with
chromatographic system what you can see
is that
our amx system is quite comparable with
that system
the grain represents our amac device
blue represents a chromatographic system
so you could see that in quite quite
of this analysis our result is
comparable
with chromatographic systems and again
uh antibody purification rate when
comparing with the automated
liquid handler what you can see is that
amx s8 system
also shows competitive and comparable
results
represented by this upper orange curve
when you compare with this lower blue
curve
which is a alh automated liquid handler
it's quite comparable and competitive
so of course purity and endotoxin is
another
major concern and when you compare our
amex system
with a resin-based simplification in the
table you can see here
the purity and endotoxin level is quite
comparable
so the upper two one are two independent
experiments
on our amex s8 flat system showing
95 7.61 percentage and 97
82 percentage curiously of purity in
comparison with
98.1 and the endotoxin
concentration is extremely low
comparable with the resin-based
purification method
of course we also produce magnetic
fields for test protein purification
including nickel charged these uh
glucosion beads
strip traveling these and recently we
launched our new product called dyk
dd ddk test purification or aka
flag tag and here i want to highlight
the once again
the second one our amax nikkor
magnetically specially designed with
binding capacity
of 10 milligrams per meal while using
six
times his test proteins and more
importantly
is ddta resistant and
sodium hydroxide washable so it can be
used
up to 100 times even up to 200 times
um for your experiment but only one
there's no strong chillator present
one this very function later you can
only use it for five to six times
so here is the figure basically to show
our amac
nico charge speeds performance
reusability and
durability you could see that after 200
cycles
its binding capacity doesn't show
obvious decrease actually it's quite
stable so indicating is a quite durable
uh necrophie
for your experiment so here this is the
table showing in comparison with our
specially designed amac
micro magnetic piece and our regular
nickel charged siege for the regular one
it has a good bonding capacity 40
milligram per mil
i'm talking about the right hand side
and
well it but it can only use uh for
four or five times and cannot be washed
by sodium hydroxide
actually we recommend we only recommend
to reuse those fees
for the same type of protein or in other
words you cannot use this
let's say a purified microbead
for protein b to avoid
cross-contamination
whereas our amac necro magnetic beads
a special special design the left hand
panel
has 10 milligram premier binding
capacity
but however it's very suitable for low
expression protein purification and more
importantly
is chelator resistance it's compatible
with
100 millimole edta and 20 minimal dct
it can be reused over 100 times but
once there's very strong chelator there
it can only use
for five to six times so i mentioned
that in my previous slide as well
and so while you work with the bigger
cultures let's say
ranging from several hundred meals to
one liter you can use
our well-designed amac tools to reduce
cell culture volume so namely i'm
talking about
a mac magnetic one and a max magnetic
block
and magnetic one consists of by two
parts
one is a steel sleeve another one
is a rod a magnetic
rod that you can put inside or magnetic
one you can put
inside the sleeves um the handling is
pretty simple and straightforward so
basically combine these two together
put in your cell culture or fermentation
and these get absorbed remove it remove
them together to appropriate
container slowly remove this magnetic
when
and then the bees fall naturally and the
magnetic block
the right hand side one actually works
in more straightforward way you just
simply stick this magnetic bar at the
bottom
or in your bottle or floss and the
magnetic fields
get absorbed instantaneously you pour
the culture medium
so what remains is these together with
your protein of interest
so basically our um accessory tools are
pretty
with high diversity high magnetic
strength
and user friendly
and of course we also provide other
accessories as you can see in this
picture
especially those two yellow magnetic
racks
used for 50 mil and 15 mil two
a pro sample let's say a
a process for manual process it can help
on that
so basically to summarize my talk
a mac sa plus system can shorten
your experimental time considerably and
can save your labor and the cost not
only the material experiment the
material cost but also the time you
spend
on each purification and it can process
12 samples at a time uh in
45 to 48 minutes and more
more importantly it's an open system it
means that there's no proprietary
buffers or consumables
bound to it you don't need to buy from
us and we provide
a wide variety of magnetic fields for
antibody
and tech protein purification we also
have our optimize the protocol
for amac and the magnetic bead system
and moreover also just mentioned that we
have a specially designed
amx magnetic feed including protein avs
which are alkaline tolerance washable by
sodium hydroxide
0.1 motor and it can be reused
up to 40 times with very high bonding
capacity
40 milligrams per mil and we also have
our amax
nico charged these which are also
alkaline but also
chelator resistance it can be washed
with one molar sodium hydroxide
and can be reused up to 100 times
and last but not least we also provide a
variety of available tools as i just
mentioned
to reduce cell culture volume of your
samples
from one liter or several hundred new to
50 mil
okay well thank you very much for your
time and your interest
in our amac actually plus purification
system
um so here you can see my contact
information so
if you're interested please feel free to
send me a message
and i really appreciate your time and
thank you very
your much and the questions
and thank you so much wayland for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions
as we have time for so let's get started
it looks like we already have some great
questions
coming in weyland how do these
beads compare with dyna beads
uh well i actually i don't want to
really go into details and we have a
detailed comparison with
between our products and with this
dynamics so
let's say if this audience really
need uh such a detailed information i
can
email the table let's say a really
detailed comparison with you
but i just mentioned that i highlighted
the feature of all these
in terms of the high bonding capacity so
this is pretty competitive
if you compare with the other b provider
and
another thing i want to highlight is
reusability
especially when i talk about protein abs
and amac bs so they are reusability can
reach to
let's say if you talk about program a
like 40 or 50 times
and a max micro bs actually you can use
it more than 100 times
so basically what i want to say is that
in comparison with
other bees in the market our bees show
very good funding capacity and even
kind of better than most of the other
providers
and also our bees can be reused for many
times
let's say um if you let's say calculate
uh the cost
in a um per use a manner so basically if
you divide uh
its actual price with its reusability
and actually the the actually actually
the price is
way lower than other than other
providers
so that's the main advantages of our
bees and
another point i want to mention is that
we even have a
let's say purification protocol based on
our bees and amac system
so basically what i want to say is that
our b's are good quality
and the price-wise speaking is
competitive
especially when you take reusability
into account
and last but not least that we have
optimized the protocol to support
our products macd and a mac class system
thank you so much kweilyn and do you
have an example where
amad beads were applied to volumes
greater than
1l to 10 l samples
well actually um we
recommend our customers to only purify
the samples
range from several meals to one liter so
of course you can try to process more
liters but it means that you have to
split your samples anyhow
so in that way you might lost your
throughput capacity
um so well i don't have a real
example but i can dig into that to ask
our
current users to see whether they use it
to purify let's say
several leaders but uh let's say um from
my point of view we only
recommend uh our customers to work on
several hundreds mills up to one liter
together with our
magnetic wand and the magnetic uh block
but uh related to actually the one of
those questions
uh asking whether um you have a higher
a higher throughput capacity version
will be available soon
actually it's irrelevant to this uh
culture volume
question and also actually i want to
answer these two questions together
and yes indeed so we are currently
developing two newer versions
one is higher throughput with 24 samples
instead of
12 so basically to double the throughput
capacity
and more moreover we are also developing
a 2 liter version
so basically to handle a bigger cell
culture
and the expecting days i well we have a
prototype we
have a prototype available you know r d
and for the official or projected
launching days
i think it would be uh the q4 of this
year and the beginning of next year i
think
because yeah we also need to take a call
with a situation into account
things are kind of going slow yep
thank you so much wayland and is it
surprising to see
uh it is it i'm sorry the next audience
member wants to say
it is surprising to see that your system
outpour
performs an alh can you provide
a case study for us uh yeah sure
so for the a specific detailed case
study i can ask our
product specialist to contact with
this audience deepak i really appreciate
your multiple question by the way
and so as i've shown in my presentation
there is a figure
with a multiple comparison so each
thought on
x-axis is one experiment so you could
see that
our amax is consistently comparable and
competitive with the
liquid handler so yeah so in my opinion
i mean in my point where it's not really
surprised to see that
because we have a sufficient data to
support our
conclusion but of course i will send you
a
detailed study if i i think i will have
your email address
at the end of this meeting i will
contact you
perfect thank you so much now is there
any plan to automate
the collection evolution buffer rather
than have the user
collect it uh yeah i hope so but
correctly with discovered version you
have to do it manually to collect
illusion buffer contain your
protein of interest but definitely and
this is really valid point we're gonna
we'll for sure
take into account when we do r d
and uh yeah to further improve or let's
say
to further expand our automation so
maybe we can do that in next version but
i definitely that's a good point i mean
the
illusion buffer collection in automatic
way for sure that's a valid point to
take into consideration but at this
moment and no you do it manually
thank you so much and i just want to
thank our audience for these great
questions
coming in we have time for a few more do
you currently have any
promotions running um
yeah well as far as i know
uh at this moment officially not
but uh we organize a promotion
on kind of regular basis quite
frequently
and also we do promotion at different uh
let's say uh locations because we are an
international file company
and we do promotion in america and also
asia persistent
and also we do promotion in europe and
um
so for instance before this christmas we
have a thirty percent
discount promotion uh with uh provided
to
aimac and its relevant products and i'm
pretty sure that
in the coming future we will have a
let's say uh to implement
uh more promotion on this new product on
amac
s8 plus system and its magnetic feeds
for sure
and you can see the update on our
website
and if you are our customers ready i
think you
will also receive our reminder for sure
thank you so much and we have time for
one more question
is it best to add the beads overnight to
your culture
um depends depends really depends your
uh experiment let's say
if your cells produce a lot of proteins
in that case you don't need to overlap
your culture you're obese with culture
overnight
only a short period of time should
disposition but uh it's let's say if you
work with
low secreted protein low concentration
prolonging into prolonging incubation is
the way to compensate on
you so in that case you do let's say
we do overnight culture and
it's necessary in order to increase the
yield
and concerning about overnight culture
and
basically you add your bees into your
cell culture you
add into let's say a main concern is
that whether it would cause
contamination
and actually we have also optimized the
protocol for deep sterilization
so you can prepare your bees and
sterilize your bees
by using our protocol and then calculate
specific amount of beef you need
and put it into a cell culture and do
overnight
incubation so in this way you avoid
contamination and additionally we also
have a macd
calculation sheet available to support
your calculation
to help you decide how much fees i want
and of course to
see how long how many hours i need for
incubation
in order to reach a specific
concentration so
for sure you can do overnight uh these
incubation
depends depends on you depending on your
experiment
thank you so much and wayland thank you
very much for your presentation today
would you like to provide our audience
with any closing remarks before we go
uh yeah sure so i just want to add two
more final comments and
currently in european market we uh
we can actually send our amacsa plus
platform
to your lab or to your company to
to give you hands-on experience so what
we do is to organize
a two days virtual workshop online i'm
only talking about
uh eu market uh so on day one so
of course after you get our amac
apparatus on day one
and you will let's say set up this amex
platform
under my or my colleague instruction and
in most
cases our local sales manager can help
outside
on day one but due to kobe 19
restriction
i don't know the situation is quite
different but let's say
correctly i mean for day one um yeah so
our customers have to do
this uh installation by himself but of
course
under our instruction online and day
second we can really run an experiment
including purification and bit sleeping
so yeah it's basically and after this
two days and the machine can stay in
your lab or in your company
for one or one half weeks for you to
gain more hands-on experience and to
really experience
if a mac is the right tool for your lab
so and of course uh the shipment fees
fourth and back
is for free it's covered by genstreet so
in order to so basically we set up this
kind of two-day virtual workshop
in order in order to overcome current a
curve is pandemic
so we do everything digitally and
another comment i want to add that
if you're really curious about our amac
s8 plus system
magnetic b's price details and
please contact our local sales
and also technical account manager and
i'm pretty sure that they can work out a
customized
and offer and package based on your
needs
so these are the two final comments i
want to add
and of course please also feel free to
contact me
you can see my information on the slide
which is showing on your screen
wayland.liu at javascript.com
so give me a call or send email and
i will guide you through uh okay i
really appreciate your time and interest
and also i want to send my appreciation
to uh
uh to organizer thanks a lot
and dr oily and lou thank you so much
for your time today
and for your important research and i
want to thank lab roots and our sponsor
jen script for underwriting today's
educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank our
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
and this webcast will be viewed on
demand lab roots will
provide and alert you a via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care and
stay healthy
bye bye everyone